if I had if I had a big yard with like a
pool and I could I would do this I'd
erect the McDonald's the golden arch
sign the illuminated red so I would see
something's wrong with you but don't you
think that would look awesome in your
backyard next to your pool as the golden
arches somewhere
in your life
McDonald's
got their hooks into you big now I don't
know if I don't know if it's a if it's a
bigger conspiracy than we even know like
someone injected you with something to
make you fiend for it and smell it at
all times I feel like if you were having
a stroke or a heart attack you'd smell
McDonald's not toasted bread not burnt
bread I swear to God if I look it up and
it's not that expensive I'm gonna ask
you if he would allow me to pay to have
it put it it will be expensive he will
not let you and you will not want him
no I think he's crazy enough I think I
think crazy enough you go yeah